[Music]
instead of your father's ring how about
you wear the cufflinks we got you oh
mama
I want to wear the ring
we had a really good life in Chicago but
they have a different set of rules down
in Mississippi you have to be extra
careful
boom be small like this
he's just going to see his cousins not a
bad thing for him to know where he come
from
even you left Mississippi mama I don't
want him seeing himself the way those
people are seeing down there
[Music]
I want to talk to you about that boy
they've gone for you
hello
the breaking news story the body of
Emmett Till has been found dead
why did it take my child from me
I need to prepare you
can you ring Emmett's black suit it's
how he'd like to be seen I was in your
kind of shape to be seen he's just the
right chain
that smell is my son's body reeking of
racial hatred now I want America to Bear
witness come with me please
the whole world has to see what happened
to my son
okay look me we have to
[Music]
you have the Public's attention we have
an opportunity
I don't want my children to have to live
in fear we do the best
we can how is risking your life gonna
help
those pictures of your son change
people's lives
one month ago I had a nice life in
Chicago I had a son
when something happened to the Negroes
in the South I said that's their
business not mine
now I know what happens to any of us
anywhere in the world had better be the
business of us all
foreign